hey guys welcome back to another video
by simply learn in today's video we'll
be learning all about react.js so let's
jump in and see what's in store for us
so we'll be covering topics on what is
react why react features of react react
prerequisites and its industry trends
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react is a javascript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
jordan walkey an engineer at facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
works in real time consider a typical
web application say instagram the entire
ui of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a
postlist component these components make
the code easier to debug and always
remain discreet components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the act helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual dom and way
data binding we'll learn about these
topics a little later in the video react
uses reusable components now this helps
decrease the development time react
involves unidirectional flow of data
react also has a small learning curve
compared to other frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to javascript using jsx
we can add html to the javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of javascript and html now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a javascript notation h1
tags indicate html again the semicolon
indicates javascript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual dom that is the
exact copy of the real dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real dom
are updated
this makes it extremely slow let's see
how react counters this now consider two
objects whose states have been changed
react now compares the virtual dom with
the virtual dom snapshot that was taken
right before the update by comparing the
new virtual dom with the pre-update
version react figures out exactly which
virtual dom objects have changed now
react only updates those objects on the
virtual dom this makes a big difference
when it comes to speed coming to the
next feature performance react uses
virtual dom as discussed earlier virtual
dog impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one way
data binding this means information
flows in only one direction one way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only javascript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
facebook instagram pinterest skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal api of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state and props are the essential
concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a javascript class having some state
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the ui looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props or short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
components more dynamic it is important
to define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of html tag attributes now consider the
following code snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that
moving on let's go through some of the
things that you should know before you
can actually start working on react you
should be familiar with programming
concepts like functions objects arrays
and classes one should also have a basic
knowledge of javascript and a
familiarity with html don't worry if you
feel like you're not good at them once
you start working on them you'll get a
good hang of it finally let's go through
the impact of react on the it industry
and get insights into the salaries of
react developers statistics show that
react developers earn way more than
other web developers according to pay
scale the average salary for a react
developer in the united states is a
whopping 91 000 us dollars the average
salary for a react developer in india is
7.25 lakhs per annum over the recent
years react has gained immense
popularity and is being adopted by many
companies according to the data by
google trends react has had a better
growth scale compared to other
frameworks like angular and vue
statistics show that front-end
developers have wholeheartedly adopted
this lightweight framework foregoing
other available options if you are
skilled and have a knack for front-end
development react can help you gain
fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react devotionally we have
facebook instagram netflix dropbox
whatsapp among others
so that is it for this video i hope you
enjoyed learning about react to gain
more in-depth knowledge about react
watch out for our upcoming videos until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here